non mais ya pas une ville comme hygiène
une ville comme idole on arrive en tête
michel-69 ferroviaire qu'elle a en tête
l'entente était communiste vous imaginez
pas qu'il ya que les électeurs de droite
votent pour nous aujourd'hui il ya une
dynamique lancée par marine le pen à la
fois sur la droite et sur la gauche tous
les les ouvriers et les classes moyennes
et populaires déçu par parti socialiste
parce que parti socialiste aujourd'hui
utilisé lectorat immigrés pour essayer
de pour faire des forces d'appoint il ya
ces gens là abandonné lâché par le
gouvernement de valls et hollande et
bien aujourd'hui se réfugient dans les
thèmes du front national et michel est
la caractéristique même une ville
ouvrière qui a été communiste et qui
aujourd'hui met en tête un candidat du
front national le vote migrer j'ai pas
bien compris la cicta a priori les heats
s'enchaînent sur le droit de vote non
parce que monsieur cambadélis disait
qu'on faisait les fontes poubelles pour
trouver nos candidats ce qui est comme
monsieur patriat voyez le parti société
très amer aujourd'hui vraiment on est on
peut voir le vrai visage du parti
socialiste qui ce qu'ils s'attaquent non
pas aux idées mais mais mais aux hommes
franciliens eh bien on montre
aujourd'hui que nos candidats bien non
seulement on les a pas trouvés un
problème et sont de qualité et
aujourd'hui je peux vous dire ils vont
faire vaciller plus d'un contondant dans
le département de l'yonne et en
bourgogne et ne s'entraîne pas